my face so red I feel like I'm inside of
a snapchat filter right now what's
happening but doesn't do anything hello
and welcome to fray diary if you did not
know for diaries and look back at my
weekend vlog farm I am in the middle of
my Grayson style book tour I'm currently
in Boston about to head to Chicago
tomorrow morning and everything's been
going really really well so let's take a
look back at how this week started this
is how I got ready for tour huh hello
friary it is Friday night 9:30 p.m. I
know I am also tired goose we are
packing for the Grace and style but tour
exciting times and we're packing
clothing for a book tour of a book based
on style so feels a little like a
high-pressure scenario this is this
scenario right now just stuff everywhere
just want to bring everything because
here's my issue I never make good
choices before I get to a place when I
travel I should like sit down to all the
stuff plan out outfits make sure I'm
only bringing what I need no I just
bring everything and then I figure it
out later so I'm all about making it
easy for present-day grace super
stressful for future grace but I'm so
excited to bring you guys along her book
tour
this thing won't be coming look at that
this buffalo plaid is huge for now and
the future maybe he's on trend goose
doesn't mess around if you take a [ __ ]
on any of these clothes I will laugh out
loud and snapchat it okay let's pack for
tour just thrilling times then we went
to New York City
[Music]
we married into a hotel see I would say
this room is like super hipster and like
trying to make fun of it but I have no
room to make fun of it because this is
what I'm wearing right now the most
trihard hipster ensemble of all time oh
my dear buzz oh yeah
um water someone in a really nice note
and this is candy made a brownie batter
too bad I'm taking a break from drinking
for a little bit I'll just be kind of
looking at that bottle of wine hi guys
we are back stage no back bookstore ugly
first book signing of the Grayson style
book tour and there's already a really
great omen here look talk about true
style icon I'm very excited this is what
I'm wearing right now
stripes boots much - oh and this shirt I
have a shirt on look cute
let psycho but cute
[Music]
hello it's the end of the first day of
the great style book talk very exciting
I've lost all the color from my face day
before the day before the book comes out
which is strange to do the first signing
two days before the book actually comes
out but very exciting for everyone that
came to the signing today because I get
the book two days early take me
seriously everything is normal on to the
next thing
Wow hello guys this is the team from
Simon & Schuster by the way yeah today
signing I think twelve hundred books
sixteen hundred bucks I'm signing today
with you go read let's do this
[Music]
we did that Diane didn't we signed 82
boxes worth of books in something like
that 1600 bucks
look at that look watch this guys look
ready well write the YouTube space doing
an event to launch some style okay okay
let's do that and then from there we did
this very good wah I like wood what it
is Grayson style book launch day we will
live all over the cameras at the rooms
I lost my mind look at that fake pan
barely tell
ah it's book lunch day I have like I
think 40 minutes or so before I have to
do a Twitter Q&A with you guys I'm very
excited about they have this new Q&A app
that I'm gonna try to use where you can
respond to questions with like video
answers and stuff it should be really
cool it looks really cool
we'll see if I know how to use it and if
I know how to use it then anyone can use
it because I'm a idiot it's been a
really good and busy day so far I did
the Today show this morning with Al
Roker and Natalie
[Music]
so they were so sweet and lovely and
that show just goes like just not like
someone admiring a beat poet but just
like so fast so much movement constant
segments and there was a dog and then I
went to Sirius XM the radio network had
Mandy Patinkin looks so sweet he's got
kind eyes
and a whole bunch of radio interviews
with really great intelligent
interesting people I've done serious
radio interviews before and they were
really great and pleasant this time
around just felt like everyone was so
genuinely curious and it didn't feel
like interviews it felt like really
great conversation with people well
times you leave interviews kind of not
worried but you wonder how you came
across and I didn't have that feeling
this time if you have heard any of the
radio interviews let me know Jenny
McCarthy was one of them who is just so
sweet I really think she's a great human
being and it works her butt off I'm
chatting so much and this is what I was
supposed to take a nap because after
this I'm gonna go meet my parents in New
Jersey to have some lunch with them
before the book signing that happens in
New Jersey tonight the sleep should be
had right now but I'm gonna go look at
Instagram yeah well yeah right
[Music]
Oh oh this place again I shouldn't do
this like this okay I'll make this quick
because this is just now silly and
ridiculous it's the end of the launch
day of Grace and style my new style
guide and it seems like a lot of you are
really liking it which makes me so happy
we had a signing in New Jersey tonight
my parents came and it's all just so
lovely and wonderful I don't know if my
hand has been on the microphone this
whole time 1 a.m. right now and I'm
exporting my Wednesday video which
hopefully by now you've seen if you
haven't go watch it it's Valentine's Day
treats it's really hard to listen and
focus to any of the words coming out my
mouth I know that so it's okay if you
don't hear anything until this clip is
over at 8:30 a.m. we leave to go to
Boston but before we leave I have to
pack up all of this yeah
anyway thank you guys for a really
amazing launch day and for those of you
that have bought the book it really is
so hard to be genuine looking like this
it really is very cool thank you and I
hope more of you buy it and I'm excited
to continue to meet more of you on this
book tour let's keep going to the next
clip
oh boy make it to Boston and I just took
my hat off and I know for sure that I'm
in Boston because my hotel room looks
like I'm staying in the White House
somewhere
Wow very Boston I just got to have lunch
with my brother who was about to go on a
quick vacation so it was nice to see him
for a second and I had a chicken pot pie
that was probably the wrong choice to
make to eat before going to a signing
well my body is like a scratch-off
ticket you just kind of hope for the
best maybe we'll win probably not though
we're in a holding pattern at the Boston
exciting look at all these Kuchar Mouse
accoutrements
now we're just talking about all the
culturally relevant things like 21
pilots and Nick Kroll and John Mulaney
boysboys behind me boy talk
[Music]
and I went to Portsmouth to talk to a
lovely woman named Virginia for a radio
show that will come out soon in front of
a lot of lovely humans and this is how
things happened this is Jim he's our
media has scored for New Hampshire
[Music]
and now here we are
Thursday night about to go to Chicago
tomorrow morning after Chicago I think
we're going to Milwaukee and then to the
Mall of America in Minnesota and then to
Austin and then to Seattle and then to
Los Angeles so go to facebook-dot-com to
see when those will be happening exactly
and where they'll be happening those
book signings and if you can come I
would love to hug you and talk to you
and do this through service said that's
pretty cool I'm like super popular in
this hotel I have to say the tour is
going really really well so far
meeting you guys it's really fun you're
all very nice you're all very very
complimentary and very sweet it's really
fun to meet you guys that's it
also if you were in the UK I'm going to
the UK after Los Angeles which is my
last stop on this domestic tour so go to
grace table book calm to see where all
the UK dates are coming because some of
you guys are tweeting at me after events
happen thing why I had no idea to be in
New Hampshire I had no idea be you be in
Boston I would have come had I known
sabra I've been telling you hey go to
grace style book calm to see where the
tour is going and if it comes to your
town hey I'd love to see you so can't
help you if you conveniently ignore me I
can't get mad at that I did it to my
parents my entire teenage years and
sometimes now so if you were in the UK
please go check out the dates and places
so that you know because we all know but
I don't know whoa what a way to end the
video except I should have ended it
already instead of continuing to talk
like this it should just ended there
that would have been a much better way
to do it
I don't know check out grace and style
the order pretending you have it my new
book it's available at all bookstores
everywhere forever maybe